all right david
david where'd you grow up where are you
from originally san diego california
san diego and uh tell me about your
family growing up you had both your mom
and dad
no my biological father uh
he was a drug addicted uh bisexual muay
thai
uh kickboxing champion uh say it again
uh bisexual drug addicted muay thai
kickboxing champion i never met him but
these are the things that my mother
relayed about he left you know
when i was first born um so i never knew
him um
but so i was raised by my mother and my
grandparents my grandparents are french
american
so my early childhood you know was good
uh and everything but um
due to what happened to my mom when she
was a kid which
must have uh had a profound uh
negative impact upon her um
mom went through well when she was uh
nine years old she
watched like paralyzed while her
mother and my biological grandmother uh
literally beat to death
um her little brother uh who would have
been my uncle
um so i don't know she just
was uh underlying you know psychotic and
it just manifested one day and she just
and my mom just you know stood there
just paralyzed and
saw the whole thing like and um so the
resulting like uh psychological trauma
that um
you know brought on with her like she
was of the type of woman that you know
just what was going through a series of
codependent relationships
usually with people with men that were
abusive
alcoholic drug addiction too but usually
alcohol
it seems is the prevalent
for some reason i know it's correlation
there is but um
so when i was uh growing up uh junior
high in high school uh
you know my stepfather clay was uh
ex-marine
militant um he was very homophobic and
uh
alcoholic and um you know i have a an
effeminate nature
you know i'm an artist a musician and um
i think that uh there was aspects of him
that uh were like a closet case you know
kind of situation that he
you know couldn't uh couldn't deal with
her except and uh so he would
lash out with you know anger and
hostility
and often you know directed at me
because i would trigger you know these
these conflicting emotions
just due to the way i am and um
so for you know all through junior high
and high school uh you know
it was like hell i i was afraid to come
home
i never ran away because i'm just not
the runaway type i should have
but i would come home you know to the
the insanity like uh
you know he would put like a post-it
note on the door if you
[ __ ] forget to lock the [ __ ] door
again i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
like it's a bit uh harsh for forgetting
to lock the door i'm just a kid
you know this time like uh my mom wanted
me to do the dishes and i'm like no i'm
not gonna do the dishes
and instead of you know a reasonable
reprimand he
threw me out into the into the space in
between the two houses and it's like a
gravel walkway and
and literally picked me up and threw me
in onto the house like
i weigh all of a hundred pounds at the
time he's an ex-marine you know
like there's like something out of a
[ __ ] marvel movie like
throws me into the wall and i you know
land in the gravel
and all that just because i didn't want
to do the goddamn dishes
and then the incident my senior year for
the yearbook photo for the yearbooks
like
i was in the basement getting ready to
go to school
trying to get you know look nice get
heated up and my friend from
from across the street zach henderson
was there too and uh
we were playing around making some noise
and we woke up you know we'll come up
and
is hangover rage and uh he
uh right in front of my friends like
threw me to the ground and was kicking
me
and and literally picked me up and threw
me out of the house like i'm
all dishelled hair's a mess crying
and like that's the yearbook photo
that's in my you know
1995 uh yearbook what a great memory
thanks a lot stepdad uh you know
and um but the uh the profound thing
about it
like moving forward in life to me is how
it never occurred to me like in my 20s
and 30s how
uh the problems that i was having like
particularly in social situations being
socially awkward anxiety
um and most most problems with
relationships
it's like one of those book smart but a
little lacking on the common sense i
didn't even occur to me like to you know
get some sort of
treatment or therapy or anything
whatsoever nothing i had
zero idea completely oblivious that i'm
all [ __ ] up
from you know being uh traumatized for
you know
five six years of my my late childhood
so um i mean that's just to me like you
know like i said i think that's the
profound
thing about it yeah in present day i
don't know if i'm
you know completely over it i'm sure
that there's still uh
you know things i suffer from as a
result but um how old are you now
i'm now 45 and uh
i came to la to pursue my music i played
drums guitar and piano
it started out great for like the very
beginning i did visual effects for a
movie called the blood sands it's a low
budget horror movie with jamie
kennedy and brooke butler so everything
seemed great when i got here you know i
had a car i had
all my music instruments and it seemed
like everything was gonna be fantastic
but piece by piece
everything's just i've been robbed over
and over and over usually
by people that i think are my friends
like i've lost everything my car's gone
like my drum set my guitars everything i
had to re-buy
my guitar four times now i luckily got
the stimulus check and bought
bought it yet again so i at least have a
guitar but um
it was just like uh
i had such high hopes and aspirations i
thought things were going to finally be
good and
uh no and i think that
this is also a partially a manifestation
of what happened to the abuse because
the relationship problems do tie into it
like i did a medical cannabis like
operation to try to recoup
some of my loss like buy a car and
everything and um
i was living with this girl in eagle
rock and she's a professional dominatrix
and we would you know
collaborate together et cetera but um
she uh you know
uh had me believing that uh she really
cared about me i genuinely thought that
she was uh you know
like maybe we would even form a
relationship of some kind you know i was
attracted to her obviously
and um i i did this whole you know thing
with this operation
i would have made you know eighteen
thousand dollars it could help get me
back on my feet and uh
right towards the end i went back to san
diego to visit some friends and i came
back the next day and
this lovely woman had completely
taken everything like like i have to
assume that she had that was her you
know intention from the get-go like
she saw me as an easy target this is a
professional dominatrix that's you know
very adept at
manipulating people and i had
no idea no clue i should have seen
warning signs
and so yet again i lose you know i lost
everything i was counting on and that's
how i ended up on the street
there because what am i gonna do stay
living with this woman of course not
i didn't have anywhere to go like i
didn't have any any jobs
in the industry lined up like so i
i that was it like i i just went on the
street and
[ __ ] was lost
so you've been on skid row for how long
now i've been a mosquito for uh
two years um broken up though i uh
i was in jail for a little while and
then um
i was at a a transitional housing in
south central but um
i have problems there you know i thought
that la would be a progressive more
progressive place but uh
i've actually encountered more ignorance
and homophobia and hatred here than
anyone else
and the management of the place where i
was at they were clearly
homophobic you know and uh they would
you know give me a hard time they came
in and like ransacked my room and
took my woman's clothing and said you're
not allowed to wear women's clothing i'm
like what the [ __ ]
who are you to tell me what i can and
can't wear this is absurd
and um yeah you know
one of the managers ended up uh you know
i tried to uh
come into my room they said i wasn't
allowed in my room and uh you know
the the one manager literally showed me
you know and there
i did nothing to garner this type of
treatment
so clearly it is uh you know they're
acting out on their discrimination
against uh
people of the uh lgbt community you know
and
uh it was really [ __ ] up because i
didn't do anything to deserve that at
all
like my room is a mess and i play heavy
metal music that's about it
so then i came back to skid row again
because i have nowhere else to go really
did you stay in a tent now i was in a
tent for
um yeah for like almost a year and uh
i don't know it's uh you know coming
from an affluent background
and you know having gone to college and
i was kind of a spoiled
rich kid in the early formative years of
my childhood you know and i'm
coming from all that like uh
going all the way from the top to the
bottom it's been a hard fall
but um one thing i can say is uh
living on the street intent is like
ultimate freedom
not uh you know romanticizing in any way
shape or form
what are the upsides of it well that
that's you know that is
like um all over the uh like rat race
uh induced stress and uh you know all
the little hang-ups
a lot of which were which are ultimately
uh arbitrary and unnecessary like you
got to make your bed and you know things
like that
it really don't matter at the end of the
day you just can forget about all that
you know
like that none of that none of that
matters like there is no schedule
there's no no rush you know which is
kind of cool as an artist a musician
like because i can just you know
play my guitar and paint like all the
time
without having uh but um over time you
start to realize
that there's uh important things that
come along with
that connection to society that when
missing for a length of time
have a very uh a very um
real impact a negative you know
detrimental impact upon your
upon your psychological well being your
psyche like
it uh it's like
for for a short time you're okay but
after a while it starts to uh
it starts to change you and degrades you
as a person
so um are drugs a part of your life
yeah yeah they um i was uh growing up i
was like real straight edge
i didn't even smoke weed or anything but
um
after everything you know everything
that's happened like uh
over and over again like you know from
from my childhood uh
you know being robbed time and time
again and uh just
you know kind of hopelessness and
everything like a depression
i did you know like many people i turned
to crystal meth
you know because uh it um
it just numbs you it like gives you
energy to uh do things be productive
and just like in one fell swoop in an
instant
takes all that [ __ ] away but i mean it
doesn't really
it just hides it just sweeps it under
the rug but um
it does it so goddamn well that it's
hard to uh
once you once you've uh uh you know
experienced that crutch is
really hard to not use it because it
works so goddamn well
you become addicted to it as well yeah
yeah i um
i can say you know there's a
differentiation that should be made
i in no way defend or uh you know
advocate
but um i'm definitely a meth addict and
i can
i wouldn't i would be lying if i said
that i didn't like it because i do
um i've been drinking like coffee all
day every day since i was a little kid
so
stimulants are obviously what my body
you know work but um
but uh luckily in my case at least like
there is a uh you know
i'm able to utilize it like in a much
more modest way like a lot of people out
here
like do you know insane amounts like
shooting it up and uh you know i use a
very very small
amount like any ball lasts me two weeks
so i mean i'm an addict for sure and
it's not something that i should keep
doing forever but um
at least uh it's not spiraled out of
control i don't go you know steal [ __ ]
or like go crazy staying up for days on
end like
so i i feel fortunate because uh even
though it uh has helped me through this
uh this really bad patch of my life um
you know it's not like i want to keep
you know just be a [ __ ]
meth addict on the streets of schedule
forever i got a degree
and like you know i got things going for
me so
it would be really uh shitty of me to
just you know
let this be the end of it
how do you support yourself no um
it's been a little bit of everything uh
at times i've turned to escorting like
um
i um thought for a while that i was
transgender because i'm very
feminine and i like wearing women's
clothing
um so uh you know that being the case
like i
um you know like a lot of people of my
ilk have
you know at many times turned to
escorting
because uh you know in my situation i'm
very limited uh
you know with what i can do like it
won't be forever
like i i'm gonna have opportunities in
the near future but um
over the course of this uh you know
being on probation and everything uh
i haven't been able to work in the
industry and uh
my teeth are all [ __ ] up i'm you know
been rendered a uh you know
a homeless drug addict but um
crystal meth is why your teeth are
messed up well yeah uh
they were already on the downfall like i
i started doing crystal about
three years ago and um they were already
like you know getting messed up but uh
certainly the amphetamine um you know
sped up exacerbated the uh
the situation and they very quickly you
know what is the mechanism behind
crystal meth destroying your teeth um
i'm not an expert on the subject but i
don't think that it is the
chemical compound or the substance
itself i think that
more more uh dramatically what is
a detriment to people's health
particularly teeth skin
uh you know psychological well-being is
the
lack of nutrients and the lack of sleep
you know sleep deprivation is extremely
harmful like how many days will you go
without sleep
um well i uh you know as i said i do i
do keep my usage pretty moderate i never
stay up for more than two days
uh you know but even that like you know
our bodies are pretty fragile so uh you
know
yeah and then i i eat you know pretty
well most of the time but uh
you know i i have to admit that i don't
have complete control over it and i do
stay up more than i should a lot
and i don't eat as much as i should a
lot and uh
so i mean it could be a lot worse you
know there's some people with a lot more
severe uh
addiction but um it's it's had a
yeah it's definitely had a detriment you
know
and do you have uh friends do you have
relationships at all
i mean uh not really because i've had
just really bad luck you know i
uh the the girl i lived with the new
rock that
brought me for that i was involved with
another uh
uh ladies friend that i met uh when i
first got here
and um similar situation i you know
thought that we were you know forming a
relationship and uh
you know she just completely uh you know
manipulated me and uh took advantage saw
me as an easy target i i
presume and um she took
everything like she took my uh my amp my
all my guitars like
everything that she could take like
almost all my my my you know
items of any value and so
you know those types of things having
happened so many times like uh
um i i don't even like like have no
trouble like trust uh you know like
i don't want to associate with anybody
i'm just like yeah don't talk to me
you're gonna all you're gonna do is
you know use me rob me treat me badly
like something
um so you're basically a loner now yeah
yeah pretty much
i have um one friend uh
in uh here in downtown and um
it's funny you know because back in
college when i was like spoiled rich
[ __ ]
you know college boy like i never would
have imagined that like
i would be a homeless drug addict on the
streets of la and my best friend is a
black uh transsexual
but uh you know she's a one of the few
really good people that actually gives a
[ __ ] about me
and uh you know that i can actually
count on and you know
so um at least i'm not completely alone
but um
what emotions do you deal with now uh
mostly uh uh my depression has gotten a
lot better
um partially just uh
you know because of uh numbing it with
drugs but also
just time you know heals always kind of
thing
a lot of frustration because i know that
my situation is
is my fault to a certain degree but is
also uh you know
the result of things that are not really
in my control and
ultimately aren't very uh fair so um
that's very frustrating because i know i
have like you know things to offer like
uh
you know i'm educated i have an insane
amount of talent my
my painting my guitar my drums like i'm
not just your average like i'm
exceptionally talented and
it's really like
um a tragedy to have somebody you know
just wasting away like this because uh
what i have to offer can like be good to
people i inspire people
like when they hear me play and see my
work like
i uh that's you know i think
the good that i have that i cannot bring
to this world it's not just entertain
it's to inspire people
if you could have changed something
about your your life or your childhood
what
what would you what would you have
changed
well uh like i said uh
maybe i should have just ran away back
in high school when i was being
abused the way i was um that may or may
not be uh
true as to whether that was a what i
should have done but um
i definitely should have um
held on to uh the relationships that i
had in the past uh because
i used to have some really amazing
people in my life and i uh
i took it for granted and now that i
have uh been relegated to [ __ ]
nothingness
like i realize like
just how special what i had was and it's
gone it's all [ __ ] gone
uh it's probably the most important
thing like i should have gotten
counseling therapy
you know um regarding the uh
effects of the abuse that i endured but
um
at the end of the day it's it's about
you know it's about your interactions
with other people i have all this talent
and i do all this amazing work but it
doesn't make a [ __ ] if i don't share it
with
other people and touch their lives and
you know
and i don't have like you know i come up
with a cool riff or a new solo or i do
an amazing painting that should be in a
gallery and it's like
hey look nobody it's empty it's hollow
there's nobody to enjoy it with there's
nobody to
make smile with what i've done
it's got to be frustrating
yeah the um
the legal system is uh very corrupt in
the city too
you know
i have a lot of relationship problems so
um
you know i often do things very very
stupid when it comes to relationships
and uh this behavior led me to uh
getting arrested as a
you know talking being involved with
uh somebody you know under 18 and so now
i'm a [ __ ] registered sex offender
and i'm treated like i'm a goddamn
[ __ ] pedophile which is
not even remotely true at all like
i'm actually a really good person but um
what would be uh you know considered
normal in any other country uh in in los
angeles uh
put me in jail and and has you know put
me on probation
and uh taking away my career it follows
you around for the rest of your life
right
um for most people it does um
fortunately for me uh it you know i
didn't actually really do anything
like it's perceived intent like you know
i did not have uh you know
relationships or any physical
interaction with this person
um you know and i i i
saw it as a potential you know
relationship like
we can you know formulate and you know
after you know a couple more years down
the road or whatever you know
kind of step-by-step kind of thing
that's in my mind like
i saw that as a viable option but um
but the point being that uh it's uh you
know considered a very low level because
i didn't you know
i didn't really do anything more than
have a verbal interaction with this
person and um
so it won't haunt me forever i will be
able to um
get my uh you know the charge expunged
more than likely and uh the registration
uh
will go away after i'm off probation in
three or four more months
so that's a big part of uh you know of
uh what's led me to the situation i'm in
and but that's only temporary thing
[ __ ] goodness um
uh after i get off probation i will uh
do what i can as far as getting sponge
mint and i want to register anymore so i
won't have the title
looming over my head which is extremely
bad you know because
when it comes to that type of thing
people are assumed the worst you know
it's like people that know me they know
that you know like uh
uh i was getting a little promiscuous
maybe but uh i'm not
you know a [ __ ] weirdo um
but after that i'm gonna move to japan
and uh
start completely all over like a whole
new life like halfway around the world
uh so that's my plan
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
um well i mean
i would like to say you know four years
college education that i have
received i was fortunate enough to get
at the audience to
not regret uh you know that at all and
even though i uh
i can't pursue my career uh it's wrong
or whatever but um
ultimately uh that's that's really the
best thing that's come
out of uh coming to la and and uh
everything that's happening here and uh
even though it's all mostly bad like you
know
all people like [ __ ] me over and
getting robbed and getting caught in the
legal system like
but the thing is when i came here i was
still just like a kid
you know i've been basically taking care
of my whole life like you know
i live with my family when i was in
college i never really was on my own
like uh i was just you know still a
spoiled brat
and like i was still superficial and
judgmental in ways that people shouldn't
be that a lot of people are like you
know see a homeless vagrant on the
street like oh my god get away from me
disgusting animal
you know like just really shitty way to
view another human being
regardless like even if they do smell
like urine and is that the other thing
it's still a [ __ ] person
and you don't know what they've been
through you don't know some of them are
shitty people
like they just you know do whatever like
you know
they don't care but like a lot of them
are you know once you actually get to
know them
are not bad people at all and they don't
deserve to be viewed like some you know
disgusting animal like like i i look
back at the way i treated people like
that and the way i acted and i'm like
i'm really glad that you know being
dragged through the mud here and all the
hardships like
i've definitely grown up like uh
it's made me a better person really like
i'm a lot more down hers and i i treat
people like
much you know decent like you know then
and and then like i don't really have
the kind of relationships that i used to
have but
but i've learned the lessons uh about
that and i know that that
at the end of the day that's the most
important thing you know
when i do uh uh you know mend myself a
bit further and uh you know kind of
get back more into society and and
eventually
you know have uh relationships with
quality people like that again
like i i won't i won't take it for
granted like i did
and i won't treat people the way i did
you know
all right david thank you so much for
talking with me and
i wish you the best of luck getting out
of here
thank you
wow
all right so ariel david you were
you were david last interview now you're
aerial
you uh you told me last time that you
sometimes have this
you like to dress as a woman sometimes
well um
some would say that it's uh partially uh
gender dysphoria
and um to a certain degree that that may
be
partially accurate but in my opinion
it's not in my opinion
um i don't know to what degree like
uh you know basically each person is uh
uh you know male and female we're we're
we're all like uh there's not as much
difference between men and women as we
like to think
even the flesh that makes our genitals
ones and anyone's an audi it's the same
flesh it's really not all that different
the wound is the big difference
but uh internally like the way i think
in the way
you know like my psyche my emotions like
there's
two people in there like i'm definitely
like very much a boy and definitely
there's a girl in there too
like it's always been this way yeah so i
don't feel it's dysphoria
i feel that i truly uh you know
have the essence of both to some degree
you spend equal time as a woman as you
do as a man
no i spend more time in boy mode
but that's all just facile superficial
uh you know as far as clothing and uh
and everything um
which puts somebody like me in a uh you
know
it has uh certain difficulties like
because
physically and romantically for example
i'm not attracted to
to men i you know i'm attracted to women
but because of
my uh physique and my demeanor and often
you know if obviously if i'm fully
dressed like a woman like
you know obviously i'm immediately
perceived as gay particularly
in this street culture of people that
are
not to be a [ __ ] but pretty much
ignorant
and uh you know very uh
very close-minded like very uh
just long hair alone like oh you're a
[ __ ]
okay i'm a heavy metal musician but
right on
glad you can figure me all out and you
know
and are there females who are into that
well that's what i was alluding to is
that in this city
not so much uh you know people are so
close-minded and uh you know
opinionated and uh just very small in
the city i thought la would be more
progressive but
there's little pockets of progression
but the vast majority of the city is
very
behind you know very very uneducated
very ignorant very like
you know outdated but um i did find in
college
like you know i uh i i dated a lot of
really quality
uh females um mostly the uh you know
foreign exchange students from asia
so
so and and sometimes you'll you'll
work as an escort yeah well
i'm grateful to have this uh
this body that i don't have to work for
i can eat whatever the hell i want i
never have to exercise i've been
the exact same weight and shape since
literally
my junior year of high school i have a
24 inch waist i do nothing to maintain
it
um point being that when uh you know my
life fell apart and um i lost my career
and
everything and i found myself uh in
a very bad predicament you know
financially and survival-wise um
you know i'm grateful that i was able to
uh you know take to uh escorting and
and i wasn't you know walking the
streets i i wasn't in skid row yet
at that time like i was in you know
hollywood and downtown like
the the more upscale area like so
not to say oh i'm a high class escort
you're a filthy you know street [ __ ]
like i'm not saying like that
um just illustrating as far as the
demographic
as well as the amount of income like um
i made twelve hundred dollars in three
days
stayed in the penthouse of the marriott
like
so it's not all uh it's not all bad
but um as i was alluding to is the um
i'm grateful for like uh you know being
able to fall back on that as a financial
thing but uh ultimately like in life
there's things that you can learn as an
escort that you can only learn
really as an escort like i uh did
crystal methamphetamine
and had you know debaucherous sexual
encounters with
um judges lawyers doctors
uh you know and there's things that i
know about these people that their
own families their own why they would be
absolutely mortified
if you know their family their wife
their kids
knew about you know some of their
predilections
but i know i know these things and uh
after doing it for a while uh you know
you you really get to see like uh
you know these kind of secrets and and
you get to understand
over time as a result uh
people on a more fundamental level are
obviously surrounding sexuality but it
uh you see you know other aspects
like you understand other aspects about
that person like as a whole not just
on the sexual thing like um
you uh race like uh race is definitely a
factor
like it's not racist but uh as far as
like
the amount of trepidation that a person
has regarding
if they're uh interested in like trans
trans uh transgender you know females uh
it very much is uh uh you could you
could separate it by race uh by far
the hispanics are the most like
i'm just gonna go ahead and say it
cowardly about it i had some that
literally ran
away like you know i thought at first
they were running away from me like oh
my god am i ugly like but over time of
doing it and seeing this behavior
over and over again and you know people
you know
showering me with praise like i came to
realize they're
running from their own [ __ ] that they
can't accept or deal with
by far the hispanics are the most like
weirded out about their own thing with
that
and the next is the blacks and then the
asians and the whites
are you know generally a lot a lot more
uh
you know they might not be uh brave
enough to um
you know be open about it to like you
know their peers
but but they're more a little bit more
comfortable and adjusted uh
you know regarding regarding those
aspects of their sexuality
so uh yeah yeah it it uh
it was it really was
and you'll uh you'll go out and
look for partners perhaps sometimes
well uh i mean as far as a female i
pretty much gave up on that in this city
uh
and then with with uh guys i uh
i i tried for a time like uh you know i
wasn't really sure
like to what extent you know my female
side and i lived
full time as ariel for a whole year like
basically was in what they call
transition
and um i tried i tried everything under
the sun i tried you know well i've been
married to a woman
for 10 years i tried dating you know
with guys
uh like like like really dang like
boyfriend girlfriend like the whole deal
and uh i did uh i had some polygamous
relationships uh with uh
married couples for a while and um at
one point one of them uh
we had started talking about me moving
in because we were seeing each other on
such a regular basis the three of us
and uh but they ended up moving uh to
another state
um so uh but after it's all said and
done um
clearly i'm uh like if if you
take away everything and just like the
main thing like i'm a cliche white boy
that has
asian fever like all about asian girls
like
type of thing you know so you're not
into
men you're into women well and and this
is what's happening to women i say i'm a
strange mix because it's like
i'm not physically romantically
attracted to men however
i [ __ ] hate wearing men's clothes i
like dressing like a girl and acting
like a girl
and i do like uh you know um
intercourse like as a as a girl like i
do like getting
you know uh with
with guys like and it's weird too
because when
when i'm uh you know having you know sex
with a man like uh
it's like it only works for me if i
if i'm like going about it as a as
though i'm a real woman
like i have to be treated that way
even though we know that i'm not like
but
i have to be treated that way like
psychologically it messes it up for me
otherwise
it's it's it's a very strange phenomenon
that occurs
like my brain knows like that you know
you're you're a guy like you you don't
have you know like you have a very
feminine body but you don't have like
you know vagina or
whatever like breasts you know but uh
my body it's like my body and my mind
are separate and my body
like demands to be treated you know like
like a woman it's it's a it's a very
like
i don't personally even understand it's
a paradox that's that's happening like
is it frustrating um not
really only in that like
the uh you know difficulties that it
creates socially like uh people
you know just assume you know that i'm
gay like call me [ __ ] like
all that childish [ __ ] i don't even
care about all of that but uh you know
but it it does make uh you know trying
to find a
female uh uh more difficult and uh
you know as much as i uh i like you know
having sex like as a woman like you know
but it's still there's no
uh romantic uh you know it's just purely
a sexual thing so
uh you know eventually i would like to
uh you know get married again
but i'm not worried about that as far as
future tense um
because uh asian girls are a lot
different most asian girls
have bi tendencies so i appeal to their
you know to their nature like you'll
notice that is the case with a lot of
the cliche like white boy asian girl
the white boy tends to be a intellectual
skinny
slightly effeminate that's what they
like
because a lot of them whether they know
it or made it or not
have buy tendencies or a full-on
bisexual i've helped a lot of them to
realize this
like honey if you're into me uh you're
probably like girls at least a little
bit
and your family oh they're totally cool
well most of them yeah
uh it was a little a little tough for my
mom at first you know
but uh this came up this
emerged at what age uh late i'm a late
bloomer uh
i didn't start uh well i mean i've been
dressing like
like a girl my whole life uh like as a
little kid i would you know
i would take like clothing like from my
mom's
or sister's closet and i would be super
careful to like put it back exactly the
way it was and
later after uh after the whole aerial
thing for a year and then
after like the dust settled and
everybody like was
okay and i i moved past thinking about
you know if i was trans and realized
that
i'm just a strange mix you know
and a lot of the girls side is is more
fetish than intrinsically who i am
um and you know so after everything
like and and i had like candid
conversations with my mom like
she's like yeah we totally knew like uh
you know a girl knows her wardrobe like
any subtle little like like they they
knew that the whole time like you know
that i was taking their clothes and
dressing in my room as a girl
uh so um they knew all along like
so i i suppose that's probably why it
wasn't that hard to like
really accept like when i started uh
brazenly going out in public dressed as
a woman
you're you're happier as a person doing
being free to do this uh yeah i mean at
the end of the day
regardless of the details pertaining to
me
like as an individual like just as a uh
as a you know a moral
and a fundamental thing like people
should be
who they are period um yeah and uh
even though like i'm an oddball mix and
it can create difficulties but
at the same time like i hate wearing
boys clothes they're boring as [ __ ]
with the same three outfits basically
like you got the jeans and
t-shirt look you got the suit and you
know like there's like
such limited options you pay like a lot
of money for
any even remotely decent quality and the
fabric the material is still garbage
compared to even cheap girl's clothes
and girls clothes is
like infinite options and all these
you know different things and
interesting like
stuff going on my friend uh tom who is a
65 year old
weekend warrior i call them which is
like he's tom the uh
the millionaire real estate speculator
during the week but on the weekends he's
picky
you know part-time uh drag queen type
thing but i always thought it was funny
his slang he calls it girl technology
like all the little complex
uh you know aspects of some girl's
attire girl technology i thought i
always thought that was funny
are you happier as a female um
[Music]
doesn't really matter i'm happier
wearing girls clothes
uh but i mean like as far as like
emotionally and romantically and all
that like definitely there's
a huge uh gap uh gaping you know
a hole in my life like that's you know
was created when my wife left me like
um you know
that's like the supersedes everything
else because
like i was saying when you when you take
away
all the uh you know enigmas and paradox
like that is the strange combination
that i am
at my core uh you know i i'm i'm more of
a
you know a heterosexual like i'm
actually it's funny because
i can be wearing you know dressing heels
but in a lot of ways i'm actually more
macho
than a lot of guys like what you would
think is the prototypical alpha males
like
i'm actually in in a lot of ways like
i'm more macho like i'm very competitive
i i listen to brutal hardcore death
metal music
like um the way i am with females like
when i'm in a relationship like uh you
know a lot of things
when the [ __ ] hits the fan you find out
who the real alphas are
and sometimes you'd be surprised who
they really are because
a lot of these men are actually scared
little boys
so um yeah i'm happier like uh
clothing-wise like but that's on a
physical
level um
you know i uh i don't cry over my wife
anymore but
i've it's been a long time since i've
been with a female and uh
it's definitely a big big part of my
life that's missing
is this why your you and your wife broke
up no we broke up
uh because of uh because of uh
overly macho [ __ ] i was a selfish
[ __ ]
and um i cheated on her like a lot
and took her for granted and like really
bad too
not like [ __ ] i was using her laptop
to talk to
girls in japan i had girls that i met
online like literally fly from japan
like to stay like in hotels with me for
like a week or so at a time like that's
how
bad it was like that's some pretty
selfish [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and uh uh one time um she was at work
and i had uh this uh one of several you
know encounters
like of that nature akiko yoshida
and um i was taking her out to the beach
for this
beach picnic thing and i cooked french
food and um i thought
lina was at work she came home early and
saw me and this [ __ ] japanese girl in
our apartment
and um i will never fully forgive myself
the look on her [ __ ] face oh my god
yeah that was like
it didn't really uh you know occurred to
me like how [ __ ] up what i was doing
was
until i saw that look that day like
that's when i
finally started to uh uh understand what
a selfish [ __ ]
[ __ ] i was like and uh i've gotten
much better like
losing everything and and you know being
trapped in this
insane cesspool and being treated like
uh
you know being underestimated so
drastically and treated badly like uh
after being a spoiled brat my whole life
it's definitely humbled me
for sure and uh in all this time of like
uh
absence of any uh female companionship
as well
i didn't know how good i had it like i
had a really really good woman
beautiful smart funny the whole you know
the whole package
i will most certainly not take it for
granted again
all right ariel thank you so much for
coming in again and sharing your story
here
you're very interesting um
that's for sure thank you very much